have you ever gone out with someone that
had no teeth at all
no I feel like Ariana Grande Put Me In
Her video and that sort of change don't
you know like she you know that changed
a lot Jenny over sort of horrible night
I love that girl she is someone that is
such an unusual sir because she's this
very very old person in a very young
body her take on things and everything
is so Advanced I don't know I don't
really know how to explain to her I've
never met anyone like her in my life
nobody with my family are you feeling it
are you feeling this high right now she
said are you high
I am so high right now
Canada doesn't get around if it had
happened earlier in my life I wouldn't
feel this high but you see it is such an
unexpected moment that I would never
have predicted in a million years I'd
already mapped out how it was going to
go and it wasn't going to go well so I
am thrilled thrilled that this moment is
having
and she was thrilled to work with an
All-Star cast and shotgun wedding I've
been looking forward to this moment ever
since baby Tommy was cut out of my
abdomen cheers everybody it was a very
cool group of people like summer camps
and Lenny Kravitz was at dinner every
night you forgot to put his shirt all
the way up
is it time for dinner Darcy I mean a lot
of women were jealous the fact that you
got to hang out with Lenny Kravitz we
didn't just shoot together we like lived
together do you know this we all lived
together in this like big beautiful
beach Mansion Castle amazing 60 000
square foot house amazing and yes Lenny
we we got to hear his beautiful voice
and it was really lovely oh someone just
left it in the bathroom
[Music]